guess who's back it's [ __ ] Daniel
Quan why don't watch you let everybody
know what you decide to do instead of
being an amazing filmmaker I've decided
to save lives and circus everyone oh you
don't rephrase the words lo and behold
they always come back even though he's
still doing it but the [ __ ]
needs money because you're begging me
back
oh because I'm begging yes I was but
that should be sale you are blue you
will do what agile autopilot oh yeah let
me look at your cross across my soul
could be having a heart-to-heart with
two different people at the same time
that's all cross my gosh oh my you look
me in the eye webs me it can besides I
want to come out whether you guys know
who Davis accommodates like [ __ ] you
alright so yes do you guys know who
David so is no I was never a bully
couldn't do it wasn't really in me but I
will say this though it's not like I you
know what maybe like what no hold on I
was not I was not a bully at all minding
my own business I always made jokes
that's that's what my role was the joke
up but I never like bullying someone I
got bullied worthy yeah
is it because he was the only Asian no I
got bullied by the kids in my oh Jesus
Randy would [ __ ] you Amanda King to me
except for you oh here go come for you
hey leave adilyn school you went to
church FL God instead you got asked oh I
was well liked in high school
but in my youth group not so much she
feed a lot your TP like Ana trusted you
going you got TP yeah my me physically
my house oh just picture the pastor just
like hey Kessler we're gonna do this
we're gonna work it out father oh my
because he maybe was like a retreat game
the whole time
oh yeah just didn't know maybe they were
just hazing you know there was all the
poison oh yeah yeah no no no no no trust
me trust me I had snaggle teeth I had
braces well lucky you bad acne Oh that
you saw anything please like hey polka
dot like some [ __ ] like that
no no they call me like inking because I
always have like sits oh my goodness
gracious no that's that's terrible
accountant oh they would ask me how my
upper lip smelled that day because I had
big gums
damn dude what kind of church did you
call these hills this is the woman you
sure you went to a church maybe you went
to a rap battle you'll get high watch a
few rap battles that is tight
maybe you seriously went to a rap battle
and you thought it was a church but
there were so many people in a circle
every kept on going this dude just came
up yo listen he can't go - Megan listen
I was listening I was crazy did you not
tell the pastor about what was going on
hey pastor these [ __ ] you know
actually there was this huge fallout
that I had with this one girl in my my
even me we did have to have
as it got it got so like deep then the
youth group pastor had to like sit down
with us and like basically counsel us
school students because it was getting
so bad you know what the cool thing
wasn't much sure so there was like
people who made fun of each other in
haze each other but then at the end of
the day it was all out of love and yeah
you wouldn't see that's how they were
with the other girls they would tease
the other girls but it was like out of
like sisterly love me they like they
came for me
like they made you do wrong yeah I made
fake Sangha accounts and like left own
cause that is super Asian it was weird
though because in highs like in my like
public school I was like I was well I'm
telling you have lots of friends I'm
pretty sure you been you're fantastic
thank you I love so too but yeah these
just say youth group kids were you have
a irony of images you're you would think
like the church kids would be nice and
then maybe like the high school kids
would be like yeah well you need is a
youth pastor like me I would have [ __ ]
those kids I like looking at those
moments and laughing though because
that's so funny yet that she cracks me
up not popping up when you were in it no
no definitely I I wouldn't have been the
one joining in I had a I had a like when
you as when you're sharing like maybe I
was related I was talking I was telling
some about my church experience and
that's like look that's what made me
realize wait wait I was bullied as a kid
I didn't realize was bullied until this
car ride no not until this crime I'm not
like yeah you're handling it pretty well
no but like a couple years ago like a
year oh I have to irritation with a
friend that was telling her how would
you tell how are you telling the story
before you realize it was bullying
there's like yeah we talked about it but
then all we were talking about like the
my youth group days
wait no I think but I think I was
bullied as a kid oh we were doing we're
talking about a unleashing trauma from
your brain cuz like sometimes you know
when your kid like when bad things
happen to you kinda just like we look it
was just like a normal conversation with
a friend it was a she's crazy she's like
a pastor friend oh okay I thought it was
just like a whatever say hey yeah I
should unleash some from get the [ __ ]
out my house you know no I think it's
definitely tough I I was never like
bullied as a kid in high school what was
everybody dan you love you do cuz cuz
you were the bully huh yes you are you
were dancing around everybody sup [ __ ]